hello everyone and welcome to a video
pretty much everyone has been requesting
uh it is uh uh my good friend stockfish
14 and in nnue uh and myself versus uh
mittens the bot now what is mittens
mittens is a newbot on chess.com you can
play against uh and the funny thing is
they've um uh they've made his rating to
B1 which is very annoying as mittens
pretty much crushes everyone and I heard
Hikaru got a draw against Mitten so okay
I guess it it is not as strong as the
most powerful engines but I'm pretty
sure it's um extremely strong so I
decided there's no real uh point in me
playing against it because mittens would
absolutely obliterate me uh so I decided
to pit it against my good friend
stockfish 14 nnue for those of you who
haven't been around the engines that
much and who don't know what nnue stands
for it stands for efficiently updatable
neural networks uh but they just um you
know wrote it backwards and then UE
instead of Eun in because why not and
well that just means it's very strong
and I've run it on leeches on the
leeches server I'm mostly allowed it to
go up to depth of maybe 2728 per move I
didn't want it to go above that as I
didn't think it would be required for it
at um at defeat or or maybe even just
get a draw from mittens and if mittens
were to crush uh stockfish at this level
then I would allow it to go even further
and um uh okay uh the cloud analysis was
active for the entire time which is
important maybe for the first few moves
because I very very quickly we go into a
position that has never been reached
before so let's check it out and let's
see how stockfish 14 and nue dealt with
mittens and why everyone is talking
about mittens well most of all because
it's a cat Everyone likes cats everyone
is now a chess playing cat of course
um uh what's better than that so let's
see how our good friend stockfish uh
dealt with with mittens so stockfish
with the white pieces opens with E4
sorry about that uh opens with the form
we have Knight to F6 by mid and
submittance goes for the aliakin's
defense Ponte E5 Knights the D5 and pawn
to D4 we have the six by mittens this is
very standard stuff Knight to F3 and now
pinning the Knight Will Bishop to G4
this is the main line of the aliakin's
defense Bishop to E2 E6 by mittens we
have castles and now main moves here for
black are just uh I go bash of the A7 or
Knight the C6 but mittens actually goes
for D captures on E5 and now let's see
how stockfish deals with this early
deviation it's not a really deviation
because it has been played before just
not at top level chess Knight captures
an E5 Bishop captures an E2 Queen
captures and now just Bishop to D6 and
here there is a game where C4 was played
but in the game we have Rook to D1 by
stockfish and it is now as of move now
find that we have a completely new game
and this is where the game becomes
extremely interesting and you can really
learn a lot from this game because
mittens is incredibly powerful and here
you will just see how uh an entity like
stockfish 14 deals with a powerful
powerful opponent so here we have
castles
um by black as well and now Pawn to see
for chasing away the knight from this
powerful D5 Square Knight to the E7 and
now Knight the C3 now Knight to F5
before continuing development and now
just Knight to F3 stockfish wants to
developed the bishop then get the Rook
into the game and stockfish likes the
bishop to G5 so he prepares it Knight to
F3 we have C6 by mittens and now Knight
the E4 improving the position of the
Knight while putting pressure on the
bishop so mittens brings it back Bishop
to C7 and now look at this Pawn to B4 as
black did not stop White's expansion on
the queen side stockfish utilize
is that the to its full potential we
have rooked the E8 and now Pawn to A4 we
have Knight to D7 nicely continuing
development and Bishop to B2 we have A6
and now Pawn to E5
um are completely paralyzing mittens's
uh Queen side we have Queen to E7
attacking the B4 Pawn but stockfish just
says Pawn to G3 I'm not interested in
that and I'm uh taking away all of your
counter play on the king side as well
and now look at this if you play Queen
captures on B4 then Bishop A3 traps the
queen okay you can still survive a
little bit later Queen captures an A5
but now Bishop C5 and you do not have
any squares left and even if Knight
captures on C5 you can even play D
captures in C5 and the black queen will
not be able to escape if Queen before
just rooked the B1 and now the black
queen must uh well be traded for The
Rook let's say captures captures and now
mittens would have to resign so of
course Mitten spots this he plays Rook 8
to d8 and now Bishop to C3 improving the
position now the B4 Pawn is nicely
defended even though it there was really
no threat of Queen capture smb4 just yet
but uh of course uh you have to play it
at some point so now Knight to D6
offering a trade and when I was uh
watching the game I thought okay now
probably Knight C5 we'll put immense
pressure on black the B7 Pawn will be
really weird there but stockfish just
goes all brute force on mittens a knight
captures and the six Bishop captures and
now Rook 8 to B1 just prepares B5 and
okay Pawn to F6 we have B5 by stockfish
C captures on B5 uh C captures and now
Rook to C8 grabbing hold of the open C
file Bishop to D2 and now a captures on
B5 with Rook captures on B5 and The Rook
to C7 defending the B7 pawn and now
mittens wants to double up on the C file
so here Bishop D3 by stockfish Rook eat
the C8 and now Rook beat the B1 putting
more pressure on that B7 pawn and now
mittens just plays Knight to B8 now the
rook and queen nicely defend the B7 pawn
and mittens has to figure out how to get
the Knight into the game probably uh via
Knight to A6 and then at some point
maybe even Knight the C5 or or B4
uh so okay uh the the this is the
position and it's not easy to continue
the game for white here but there is one
move which completely shatters Black's
position and unless you are stockfish
you are not finding this move or unless
you are you know a a really inspired
style uh you if you are not finding this
move so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a true
master of positional chess and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Pawn to D5 and now once you see
this move of course it all makes sense
now there isn't pretty much nothing more
for black to do here uh Black's position
is just uh unplayable I mean it's it's
incredibly difficult to imagine this but
that's just how strong stockfish is so
really congratulations to everyone who
considered D5 the problem is you don't
have a good response to this if you play
ecaptress on D5 then then just Queen to
D1 is enough there's no good way to
defend the D5 pawn and then the queen
will also set up an attack towards the
B7 Pawn if you try Queen F7 to defend it
just Queen captures Queen captures and
now Rook captures on D5 and what do you
play now the bishop is hanging let's say
you move the bishop look at this bishop
F4 and again no no move here for black
if you try a rook to F7 or Rook D7
doesn't really matter you you just
captured the Knight here Rook captures
and A6 and black just resigns here
there's no good way to to deal with this
so that's what happens if you capture
the pawn not capturing the pawn not much
better Knight is coming to D4 we'll put
additional pressure and at some point
you will have to decide whether to play
E5 or E characters on D5 but whatever
you decide the Knight will get to the F5
square and that again big trouble for
black if white is a stockfish of course
so Mitten says all right let's try E5
but this isn't much better yes it
prevents Knights to D4 and it keeps the
position closed but now stockfish plays
Knight to H for going for that F5 square
and the mittens plays G6 and while uh
mittens really did a fine job keeping
that Knight in Bay at Bay it weakened
the king a little too much so now Queen
to G4 stockfish again with a deadly
threat of just Rook captures on B7
because Rook captures on B7 will be met
with Queen captures and CA to check and
then you will just pick up the Rook on
B7 so how do you play this King F7 by
emittance and now Rook to B6 just the
suffocating mittens I mean mittens is so
cute and this is all very sad but um I
may have paired mittens against uh too
strong of an opponent so here at Mitten
says all right now it's finally time to
activate this Knight to get it into the
game Knight to A6 is played but now
Knight to F3 and now look at this we
have Ponte H5 now once the Knight moved
you are threatening to bring the queen
into the game via the king side Ponte H5
now Queen A4 and now finally Knights the
C5 the Knight is activated but mittens
shows that uh well nothing really to it
just Bishop captures and C5 and now if
Rook captures you have Rook captures on
B7 and if Bishop captures what was
played in the game Rook to E6 incredible
that uh all of this is possible because
of that the D5 move all of these tactics
become possible so now you could play
Bishop captures in F2 it seems like a
very good tactical resource if King
captures Queen to C5 check but just King
G2 and uh well now all of the all of the
problems just remain so after Rook D6
Queen to f8 by mittens and now Queen to
E4 now stockfish is ready to sacrifice
an E5 and completely bust open the
position and then some nice ideas like
Rook to B3 Rook to F3 are coming this is
total Annihilation we have Queen to G7
now King to G2 not even allowing any
tricks with Bishop captures on F2 Rook
to D7 and now Pawn to A6 absolutely
incredibly
uh created by stockfish because uh how
do you how do you deal with this uh now
if if you capture you lose control over
the C6 Square now look at how strong
Rook the C6 is it doesn't matter if you
capture or or you defend the Rook let's
say queen to G8 look at this Rook to C1
attacks the bishop you can't move the
bishop because of Rook captures and C8
that's just it they throw capture spawn
captures now the rock is hanging the
bishop is hanging and here mittens would
just have to resign so again mittens is
forced to keep the position closed B6
but now uh he just gives stockfish a
very strong past a a pawn now Rook to B3
preparing to sacrifice the Knight and
then bring the Rook into the attack via
the F3 Square uh now comes the bishop
back to E7 this is sort of giving up the
B6 Pawn but how do you play if Rook day
8 or anything like going after the pawn
here's your sacrifice for capture spawn
capture so Rook to F3 check and that's
it let's say King hero captures on G6
and that's it black resigns so after
Rook to B3 Bishop to E7 is played and
now just a rook capture Sun B6 stockfish
oh okay Knight captures an E5 was also a
move but Stockbridge decides to create a
past a pawn first and now again Knight
captures uh an E5 that's a weird Arrow
story Knight captures an E5 Rook
captures on G6 will now be even stronger
with the Rook doubled up Rooks doubled
up on the sixth rank so Queen to G8
mittens now uh gasping for air here
there's really no nothing more to be
done Knight captures an E5 F capture so
Rook captures on G6 Queen to f8 and now
Queen captures an E5 we have King King
the E8 but now just Pawn to D6 all
possible because of that pawn to D5 move
absolutely incredible H4 mittens now
just uh you know uh throwing his little
paws around really just making silly
moves D captures an E7 H3 with check now
even King captures an H3 nothing to
worry about here Queen to F7 and now
Rook to H6 going for that final Rook to
h8 to check Queen to G8 Rook to h8 and
now just captures captures King to F7
was played and now a very quick Ending
by stockfish Queen to H7 check King to
E8 and now Queen to G8 check forcing a
black to capture the pawn mittens
capture Sun E7 but now Rook the E6 is
Checkmate uh absolutely incredible and
and I have to apologize to all the cat
lovers out there I did not expect
mittens to get crushed so hard I really
thought he was much much stronger even
though okay as Hikaru said that he got a
draw against that players uh did get
draws against really really powerful
engines so I thought okay probably
mittens will be a bit more formidable
but okay I did a parrot against the
absolute strongest opponent that there
is available okay I could go even
stronger I could go to a bigger depth so
it would require require more time for
me to
um even attempt such a video but I
thought okay maybe if mittens survives
this then we're gonna you know deal with
that but okay stockfish is just a beast
and a completely different level uh but
you know mittens really really
uh did a nice job and especially since
mittens didn't really uh go into main
Theory already here mittens went for D
captures on E5 which is considered sort
of a lesser move and not not even played
at the absolute top level uh but maybe
even it's not because even uh even the
engine says like it's it's a perfectly
fine move so it's hard to say where
mittens uh went wrong uh it's uh it's
probably just that stockfish every every
move they made stockfish was like a
little bit better a little bit better
and then over the course of 30 moves it
just piled up into stockfish being a
whole lot better uh but I mean the game
that that happened I mean it was just an
absolute Masterpiece and this D5 move I
mean wow what a game absolutely
incredible uh something uh we we see
very very rarely I mean in classical
chess maybe at the absolute highest
level uh like a game that would happen
once a year so hope you enjoyed this
once again really sorry for for
stockfish crushing it's like this I
expected mittens to be stronger but you
know uh what are you gonna do it was not
my intent to you know just really uh
stockfish for to destroy mittens like
this uh but but it happened yeah so yeah
really really sorry for that uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
as everyone has been requesting me to
show a game by mittens uh as Mitten says
I am a tiger and you are in the jungle I
call eternity well uh uh you know when
stockfish enters the jungle no one no
one no no one survives uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed that
I would like to thank
you and mittens for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and remember that none of
this would be possible if stockfish did
not start this beautiful queen side
attack with Pawn to B4 and then
everything just continued piling up
thank you all I will see you soon have
an excellent rest of your day